welcome back to cbs this morning a
record 16 million americans have
reportedly already cast ballots
for president this year but just because
a ballot is returned early
does not mean it will be counted early
or at all
more than 300 election-related lawsuits
in at least 40 states have been filed
this year
and many challenge some aspect of mailed
ballots including witness requirements
and ballot deadlines we got rare behind
the scenes
access to an election office to show you
what might happen to your ballot
once it arrives to be counted
oh see we got a good amount wow
results in the 2020 election are already
pouring in
heavier than yesterday these are
absentee ballots in rockland county new
york
democracy happening before our eyes
and kristen zabrausti stavisky and
patricia giblin are co-election
commissioners here
a democrat and a republican working
together
can i help you um sure
really all right rhonda you're in
joe you're in see that but nationally
republicans and democrats are fighting
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen not only to turn out their
voters he is throwing up
every roadblock to try and suppress the
vote
but to make sure that each vote is
legitimate and counted
and sometimes when there are challenges
people will say you know without that
stamp we're not sure when it got here
what you're about to see
is perhaps the most consequential moment
in the journey of a typical mail-in
ballot
so the first thing we would do is scan
it in
and then we're going to just view the
signature
oh wow when election workers try to
verify
that a vote is genuine but checking the
signature against what's on file
trisha and i would make a ruling yep
while the commissioners asked us to blur
voters names we got to see
exactly how much variation they're
willing to accept
we're looking at substantial
similarities right so we're not
handwriting experts we're not sitting
there saying oh that y is
slightly different that's not going to
count if your ballot is going to get
hung up though this is most likely where
it will happen
and in a close election that could be
decisive
across the u.s missing or mismatched
signatures
doomed more than a hundred and fifty
thousand ballots in 2016
and sure enough this looks very
different
very different yeah so that's an issue
this voter's signature
sent the commissioners in search of
additional documentation
so now we're going to look at her
absentee application
batman matches and we watched as they
looked through four signatures on file
so it almost appears like she has
a very serious signature as the voters
say a quick signature
it just seems like the pen strokes are
different i don't
i don't want to get involved it's your
call the decision
rejected at least for now we may talk to
her
and see she may sign an attestation that
she actually completed the ballot
in new york and at least 18 other states
voters are notified if their ballot has
been rejected
and given an opportunity to fix it in a
process known as
ballot curing but in most of the country
there is no such requirement
so the ballots can be tossed out and not
only for signature issues
this isn't sealed we saw two other
ballots set aside because the internal
envelopes
weren't sealed though those were
eventually accepted with no evidence of
tampering this right here
just to put a fine point on it this
demonstrates why it's so important for
people to take extreme care
that's right when they're filling out
their ballot that's right after the
initial checks the sealed ballots are
scanned in
and moved to a storage room it's really
secure
look at that all right there's three
locks
democratic lock a republican lock and if
we were ever
impounded by the court that lock would
be for the sheriff
in new york they aren't actually counted
until three days after the polls close
so state officials can compare a list of
absentee voters against the names of
those who voted in person
so the point of the delay in counting is
to make sure
no one is double voting yes yes election
results are always unofficial
on election night that's true for every
state in america
where any vote can be contested or even
thrown out
and this year that fight is expected to
be fiercer than most
why at this busy time did you want to
show us this
i think it's all about transparency we
want to show the voters
first how hard we work that their ballot
is going to be secure
when it's here and then we're concerned
about their ballot and we will take
every precaution we can
we want to demystify it right people
don't know when they're
nervous about things because they don't
know so
even though we're extremely busy right
now this gives us the opportunity to say
to people look this is what happens to
your ballot
we take it seriously we want your vote
to be counted
and these are all the steps we take to
make sure it does isn't that interesting
it gives me comfort
seeing how hard they were number one i
didn't realize that you had to work that
hard in terms of
checking double checking rechecking
again and the fact that they take it so
seriously and that they allowed you to
come in and see it i like that there are
partisan locks
a republican lock in the democratic so
there are two
uh keys for the storage room but also
two keys for the dropbox outside so
nothing in that office can happen
without a republican and a democrat
signing off
and that's in fact true all across the
country there's a lot of of states that
have
that kind of dual system of checking
yeah but here's a message i'll bring
people from the republican commissioner
uh miss giblin there in the piece
she says if you can vote in person you
should do it
because there is less of a chance that
something will get
hung up yeah if you do it in person yeah
i think you can see why well
the very important point you made there
about the signature because because i
mean one thing i've noticed
in these days when people sign for
everything you know paying by card
barely a sign
people just literally slash online but
you if when you go vote in person you
can usually see your signature that you
registered with
and you and you can know to match it and
sometimes people now are signing so many
different ways and you're there you pull
the lever or you
fill in the bubble and your signature
you're counted right there on the spot
yes if you vote by mail
as trisha giblin put it you are inviting
people to challenge it they have the
right to challenge it if you're voting
on that piece of paper
now another thing i'll point out this is
important 18 states have to actually
call you
to say hey there's a problem most of the
country that's not the case
however however right now people if
you're worried if you've already voted
you can use the ballot tracking method
in your state most states have that
uh and if you want more information
about exactly how to get this all
just right because it really does matter
you get about to give yourself
i'm gonna give this please visit cbs
news you got
all the information just we'll just call
you yep
big thing the the signature and seal the
envelope seal the envelope be very
careful
and follow up to make sure it's been
accepted because you may not get a call
all right and next week we're sending
tony on the road
and a trip through some of the most
critical crucial battleground states for
a series of reports called
at america's crossroads tony will talk
to voters about the issues that matter
to them in the places that could help
decide
the 2020 presidential election that
starts monday
right here but tony will be out before
that right here on cbs this morning